this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your mental health your
relationships your work your money
anything and everything we're here for
you i'm john dalone joined by my good
friend and best-selling author ken
coleman and we are taking your calls on
life triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you're struggling with
relationships at home
can we we know businesses are slowly
starting to open back up and people are
trying to figure out after a year two
years of working at home what it's going
to be like to travel again or drive or
those who have been back in workplaces
are looking to shift and change if
you're dealing with leadership
challenges where you work if you're
dealing with personal relationships
money challenges whatever's going on
give us a shout triple eight eight two
five five two two five let's go to
jasmine in seattle hey jasmine what's
going on
hi um thank you for taking my call today
you bet thanks for calling what's going
on um
i
over the weekend um was the end of my
relationship um
i
am
a mom to a one and four year old and
we
left
and
came to my mom's in seattle we were in
alaska
and
now i am looking at fighting for custody
and
um
trying to figure out how to start life
on my own as a single mom
at 26 and
it's just kind of scary
that's so scary why'd you leave alaska
what happened
um
well
the kid's dad
is an alcoholic and
has struggled with
substance abuse
with other other drugs
and
he's
not physically abusive but
mentally emotionally
financially and
um
it's been
like two years up there of just the same
pattern of
things going okay for
a couple weeks and then
he starts going out all night not
answering the phone and
just like disappears on a bender and so
what happened what made you say this is
enough is enough is enough i'm out of
here i'm getting my two little ones and
we're going
um
well we got into an argument
and he told me to leave
i brought the kids with me because he
was intoxicated at the time
and then
he came and got them from me
intoxicated and i didn't
i was scared i didn't know what to do i
didn't feel safe trying to go and get
them physically myself
and i called the police good for you
good for you jasmine good for you and i
know that's hard but you did the right
thing so how can we help what can i help
you with
um
i think the biggest thing is i'm just
worried about the kids because they're
still really young so
i don't think they fully understand
what's happening and why we're not with
dad and why we're not in alaska and um
i'm mostly just trying to explain to a
four-year-old you know um she saw daddy
get arrested you know
so i think the most important thing now
is to solve for things in order okay
so the first thing i want you to do is
solve for safe solve for safety and
you're with your parents now you said
yeah i'm with my mom and that's a safe
place for you
yeah and by safe i mean not just not
abusive but there's food there's shelter
you got the lights are on that's a good
place
yes great
or
it's going to be tempting to try to talk
explain things to your kids what your
kids need right now
is you
and your presence and your mom's
presence they need adults in their life
to be calm and stable and not that
they're not going to be grieving or be
upset or weeping anything like that but
they are going to be able to look them
in the eye to go for a walk right
touch presence connection is going to
speak volumes to them right now and when
they ask questions we're not going to
talk bad about dad dad's struggling with
stuff but we are going to tell the truth
and we're going to tell him daddy's
struggling and we're going to be staying
here for a little while
and then i want you to start to think
over time what is this what's it going
to mean legally what are the legal
ramifications and are you going to get a
professional to walk through that with
you
do you have a community of
other women in your life that it's not
your mom that you can sit down and just
say this socks with
um well
i'm starting to kind of build that in
fairbanks good
um but i do have i have cousins and and
other extended family here in washington
as well good
so one more thing
i want you to go to betterhelp.com and i
know you've just moved to a new town and
you can go to
betterhelp.com they'll give you a
discount i want you to find a
professional counselor to start talking
to today
will you promise that you'll do
that yes thank you
and
talking with a professional is going to
they're going to walk alongside you and
they're going to be with you not just on
a 10-minute phone call on the radio but
they're going to be with you tomorrow
and the week after that and the week
after that and if you have access to
counseling resources there in your
community great i would reach out to
somebody because you're going to want
someone to walk with you over the next
few weeks few months
uh john and jasmine i want to give you
something and john i want you to
prescribe this i don't know what the
timing is from a counseling standpoint
but while you're getting healthy and
while she's getting healthy there's a
season on that however jasmine as soon
as john thinks it's smart
i want you to in the near future
begin to focus on your future
that's today jasmine
okay good yeah once you're safe we gotta
start looking for how are we gonna eat
so there's two things i want you to do
i'm glad you're safe with mom
but i want you to focus on provision and
contribution those are your two words
okay provision means
i want you to figure out what work looks
like for you it doesn't have to be dream
job yet we're not worried about that i
just want you to get into the act of
getting into work
and knowing that you as a single mom are
enough and that you can provide for
those little ones because you've gone
through some tremendous stuff and it
begins to make you doubt so much and i
want you to show yourself that you can
and you will provide for those
beautiful children so that's provision
okay
the second thing is as you get on your
feet you begin to work and you begin to
see that you can provide and that you
are strong enough i want you to begin to
think and i want you to begin to wonder
what is it that i want to do
um do i want to eventually get married
and be a stay-at-home mom that's great
so you're working for a season or is
there something professional that you
want to do a contribution that you want
to make
and make that contribution find work
where you see value in your work there's
value in all work but i want you to
maybe look for work in seattle where you
are making a difference in the lives of
people that you connect to i think
that's important to the healing process
so those are your words provision and
contribution and i think it's going to
help speed up your healing jasmine
because no matter what he said or did to
you you have a tremendous amount of
value to the world not just to those
kiddos you got me
yeah thank you and jasmine one more
thing
one of the great evils of abusive
relationships is that you look in the
mirror and you begin to believe that
nonsense yeah and i want you to hear me
and ken say
you're worthy of being loved
you did the right thing taking care of
those kids
and you have value regardless of what
some knucklehead has told you
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
um
[Music]
825-5225 this is the ramsey show we're
taking your calls on your money your
life your relationships your work
whatever's going on in your life give us
a shout triple eight eight two five
five two two five
ken you've got some
articles here brother yeah so i i
thought
this is the reality uh where we uh
need to be talking about this so let's
just set the table
since august of 2021
uh to november december of 2021 we saw
18.5
plus
million people change jobs
okay so you can textualize that for me
in history because that feels like it's
just one of those great migrations that
happens it is so for people aren't
paying attention to this in the news a
lot of economists have called this the
great resignation but to answer your
question it's historic in that each
month we had 4.2 4.3 4.5 each month
august through december was 4 million
plus that had never happened before any
one of those months would have been a
record
getting people leaving in one month so
never before in the history of the
american economy
had four million people
left a job in one month
so then do that times four or five
so it just kept going we'll see the job
numbers coming out soon yeah uh and so
we'll see is it continuing a lot of
people think it's going to continue so
but that it's not affecting the overall
unemployment rate so they're leaving
jobs to go to other jobs no it's a big
it's i'll tell you what it is it's a bit
of musical chairs right okay because all
these people are leaving so everybody's
leveling up so let's say uh somebody
leaves so sarah leaves company xyz
to go to company abc
so that leaves a hole a company xyz
sarah left company xyz to go to abc for
a bump
so that puts company xyz in a hole what
am i gonna have to pay somebody now is
paying sarah this much money
to replace her i'm gonna have to pay her
more
so a part of this inflation stuff we
hear now let's talk about money here on
the ramsay show it's a money show a part
of the inflation
is the cost of jobs
so coming out of the pandemic we saw
hourly rates go up
so
walmart target
amazon they jump in and they go all
right
forget the federal government we're
going to raise our minimum wage to 15 17
an hour
so then becomes an arms race
so companies are competing for talent
and people are leveling up and making
more money
so is there coming break-even point when
the business is better off
looking at the people who are thinking
about leaving and taking care of them
before they jump shut 100
so i'm hearing a lot of conversations
about what does a workplace environment
look like that's becomes more hospitable
and becomes more retention focused and
holistic then
i'm giving you this wage i own you for
the next eight hours that's right then
we'll get up and do it again tomorrow
and so what's happened because that has
been
the general leadership view you need a
job
and so i don't have to treat you
probably as well as i need to well then
the pandemic comes along new jobs are
created opportunities and people are
going wait a second you're treating me
like a commodity that i'm gonna go get
mine and see i i wonder if there's even
a psychological component to oh this can
all end
any moment
i'm gonna live my life on my terms more
than let some
let
some boss that i don't know in some
suite across the country run my life
that's exactly right so
we bring this article to you today
because john here's the reality in an
audience this large
there are people out there who are going
you know what my work is literally
making me sick
right
so here are
uh from comptia.org okay these are signs
that your job is making you sick i'm
going to run through these quickly john
and then and then you and i are going to
break this down what is leadership doing
that are creating these physical
symptoms
and then what does a person do
to try to treat themselves in the
process of deciding do i leave this
environment so here we go one is
insomnia you can't sleep a lot of this
is due to work stress can't get your
mind off of work
and you lay down at night physically and
mentally and emotionally exhausted and
still can't go to sleep uh another one
is you sleep too much
all right so you're sleeping too much to
cope with all of the uh elevated
adrenaline and cortisol levels uh three
you're losing weight
you can't even think about eating
because you're so focused on the
fight-or-flight mode from the work four
you're gaining weight
as the adrenaline and cortisol levels
increase due to challenging work
environment it's not uncommon to put on
weight so i know that i'm an emotional
eater so if i had somebody john come at
me
and get all over me and a boss treat me
like a you know just like i'm a piece of
junk
i'm hitting the chips and salsa oh yeah
i'm just telling you yeah so so i i just
want people to go hey there's no shame
in your game number four that would be
me and when my boss calls me in and says
i just need you to know
you are doing incredible work i go
celebrate with chips and salsa that too
i am an emotional leader i'll have john
diagnose me during the break no i'm the
worst right number five you feel tired
and unmotivated obviously uh fatigue
here high stress too long it's gonna zap
you number six you get colds more often
john you're the first one to kind of
tell me about this i didn't realize how
much stress affects our immune system
yeah it's unbelievable number seven
takes you longer to recover from minor
illnesses because of again
all the factors we've been walking
through number eight you exercise less
off less often you have no motivation
nine you're withdrawing socially
because that unhappiness at work bleeds
into your personal life
and then 10 your doctor starts to
express concern blood pressure
cholesterol levels all
physical effects as a result of a toxic
environment or a horrible boss and i
want to point out a couple things real
quick one
we often look at what our neighbor in
our workplace is going through you think
i'm not going through that
this is important to point out because
stress affects different people
differently because of their life
experiences because of their genetics
because of trauma or not
this stuff ping-pong's around so it's
really important to know your body and i
also think it's important to note this
isn't all causal right this isn't this
causes that this that causes that
usually what happens is you find
yourself so stressed out
like we got here on the back you stop
taking care of your diet yeah quit
working out you quit hanging out with
other people you spend more time
scrolling less time sleeping and all of
a sudden these things start stacking up
on i agree and i think what you just
said is is absolutely important for
people to hear we compound the problem
so let's i just wanted to briefly touch
on a couple leadership things but i want
you to tell the audience okay what do
you do
like how do you self-care in a situation
where you can't leave right away right
cause we let's stress this
we never tell anybody on the king
coleman show or the ramsay show hey
if you're in a tough environment
just walk out today yeah no no no no no
if you financially can then we say yes
but unless unless you've got the
financial wherewithal and freedom to do
so you're gonna have to come up with a
plan and john i want you to talk about
what they can do for self-care but let
me just identify because i want people
to understand that this isn't okay
and so when you've got a leader
who is basically taking their burden and
dumping it on you
and they're going you got to do more
because i can't do anything about it
they're not shouldering the load with
you they're not going this is for a
season this is only going to be here or
they're not rewarding you as a part of
this you are feeling like you are
nothing more than just a person who does
whatever they want whenever they need it
there's no value and that starts to wear
on people that's right that's what's
driving this is people feeling like a
commodity not a person well and and they
get
as our friend jacob says there they get
no ownership that's it yet all the
responsibility yeah right you don't get
to decide what's going nobody asks your
opinion they tell you what you're going
to do and how you're going to do it when
you're going to do it
and then that's a recipe for dude
i'm going to go have some sort of
autonomy and and be able to speak into
my life what can the audience do if
they're in this situation to at least
stem the tide of these negative physical
things i think the the most important
thing they can do is to acknowledge this
is happening yeah most of us don't have
it took me years to figure out and draw
begin to connect the dots in my life
that this work environment that i have
to be honest to look in the mirror not
always
but often i was allowing or i was taking
on too much because i wanted to get an
extra certificate or an extra gold star
i was carrying things about my business
and my industry that nobody asked me to
carry right that's not everybody right
that's me
you have to call it out and say this is
killing me
this is melting my marriage or i'm not
being the parent i could be because of
this you got to start there with owning
being honest and then
it it sounds so uh trite but all you can
do in these situations is control two
things on planet earth you your your
thoughts your actions yes that's it my
brother that's it don't be afraid to ask
for help
for help ask people to help you with
your thoughts ask for people to help you
with a workout plan ask people to help
you with sleep go see a doctor and then
start asking people to walk it walk
alongside you as they help you find a
new place to work
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
from sumner south carolina on the phone
we have jeff and it says here on my
screen that you
are debt free
jeff are you there
i'm in here can you hear me oh yes hey
uh a cool thing you do when you're
talking to somebody on the phone is to
pick it up so my bad let's start that
again jeff from sumner south carolina my
screen says you're debt free is that
right
that is correct congratulations my
brother how much have you paid off
i paid off the last 30 000
and that was to my mortgage wow wow you
did it so what was your total amount of
your entire journey
uh for the
for the mortgage no for the entire your
entire debt free adventure here
that was it 30 000
was my mortgage i am totally totally
debt free wow phenomenal man so how long
have you been uh on this journey
uh this is uh this is over the last 12
months
and what was your income in this time
a little over 50 000 a little over 50
000 and you cranked out 30 000 of that
yes it was tight but it was right
that's well done there so what do you do
for a living brother
i'm actually a retired military retired
air force oh retired air force thank you
for your service yes sir
so what happened a year ago that you
said i'm sick of having a mortgage i'm
done with this and i'm going to send
more than half of my annual salary to
get this thing paid off
well it actually was gonna be a year
earlier but this uh this virus thing
kicked up and i was like i better push
on the brakes a little bit slow down on
my uh
intense uh payoff on this mortgage but
then i let up off the break this this
last year and i just went for it and i
just paid it all off i just i was like i
am done paying the bank any more money
that i have to i am getting out of this
so i paid it off uh real quick aside
jeff what virus are you talking about
just kidding just kidding
all right there's a rumor going around
there's a virus out there so
so you decide a year ago i'm i i'm done
with this thing i'm gonna get this
through how did you get connected to the
ramsay squad
i i've been listening uh for quite a
while um i can't get it locally so i've
been listening on the iheart radio so i
listen mostly to the podcast but i've
been listening pretty carefully and
every uh every debt free screen gets me
that much more pumped up to do my own
screen
that's fantastic
so walk us through your
journey what was the key to getting out
of debt
i think just uh just getting out of debt
just having that vision of like what
could i be doing with this this money
that i'm paying to my mortgage in
another more positive way other than
giving it back to the bank plus all
their interest
and uh i just think i'm done with it
especially when you're on a fixed income
is because this is this is basically my
income is my pension so there wasn't a
lot of outside money's coming in so i
was like you know i'm on a fixed income
i want to use as much of that as i can
and getting rid of this this mortgage
this debt is going to give you much more
uh possibilities
now jeff you said uh it was tight but it
was right and that by the way that's the
bumper sticker of the day that's
fantastic my question is how tight was
it what were some of the big sacrifices
you had to make
you know um i kind of you know it is
over time because this obviously my
mortgage is uh paid off in 11 years so
it's actually pretty early but um so i
gradually and gradually kept paying more
and more so i just kind of eased back on
any kind of extra spending but i didn't
uh you know my spending was pretty
my budget was pretty tight anyway as far
as not not too much extremes or anything
so it wasn't a big sacrifice but you
know just uh not going out for meals
cooking everything at home just doing
the traditional rice and beans beans and
rice kind of a kind of diet as well as
everything else is kind of
fixated on getting this mortgage paid
off so anything else was was basically
this can wait i don't have to nothing
nothing to just pay my bills and pay the
mortgage and get out of this yeah when i
look at focus when i look at just the
math
30 000 bucks over 12 months against a
fifty thousand dollar salary you were
living quite spartan my man
like you you were for real beans and
rice like what was that what is there
something you're never gonna eat again
as a result of this journey
no not really i mean uh you know i guess
i'm pretty set in my my ways as far as
i'm pretty you know everything's kind of
uh uh
everything's the same so no no i
remember a long time ago when i was when
i was promotion testing i i lived on
bologna sandwiches every day for lunch
while i was testifying i was preparing
for my tests on so i will never eat
bologna again that's for one thing all
right all right that does rhyme with my
last name
but it was good it was you know and i
think you got to go through the um the
struggle it makes it makes you feel much
better when you're finally over that
hump and get that last at last send in
that last check that's right it just
makes it that much much sweeter so jeff
who was your biggest cheerleaders when
you were going through this
um you know i i kind of kept on the down
low uh because you know it's one of
those things like am i really going to
make this is this really going to happen
so i didn't put a lot of like hey this
is what i'm doing kind of thing but i
did tell people hey so i'm doing this
and they they just kind of said yeah
that's nice
because you know everybody has debt and
everybody thinks you're going to get out
of it but you got to want to get out of
that debt you want to get to the other
side and that's why i wanted it and i i
got it i see that picture of you up on
our screen with that beautiful yellow
lab what's the dog's name
that is casper casper was with you the
whole time that's kind of cool oh yes so
did you did your friends and colleagues
think you were nuts during this journey
did they what think you were just had
gone bonkers
uh not really i didn't really you know
um throw it over their heads all the
time and stuff but i just kept saying
hey i'm paying down my mortgage paying
down my mortgage this is all i got to go
on this you know this is all the debt i
have and they're like kind of kind of
amazed by that because you know
everybody's car loans and everything
else and stuff but i only had one thing
and uh so they were probably maybe
envious uh you know under their breath
but i didn't really tell a lot of people
about it because i wasn't sure it's
gonna it was gonna happen until it
happened so if somebody is sitting there
just with their headphones in they're
doing their job they're driving
somewhere
tell them what it feels like to not owe
anybody
anything
it feels
like the weight of the world is off your
shoulders
because no matter what happens
your house is paid for everything is
paid for
it just makes life as as dave says you
know walking through the grass it feels
fresher although it's winter time so i'm
not walking barefoot to the grass right
now but it's uh it feels fresher the
grass still feels better everything
feels it just feels different the house
even seems larger now
oh yeah i you know i'm curious have you
allowed yourself to wonder
dream a little bit
now that you're on the other side of
this debt i'm curious what are you
thinking about now that life has changed
and you can actually do something more
with that money yes um the first thing
i'm going to do is basically my my plan
for the next six months is putting that
same amount of money that i was paying
down the house with which is a large
amount
into savings and then this summer i'm
gonna do the give live and give like no
one else uh
uh motto and hoping to get involved with
some some of the boys and girls clubs
around here and see if there's anything
i can do as far as helping kids go to
camp they can't afford it you're an
amazing human being
that is cool well jeff we've got a copy
of the legacy journey for you and we're
going to give you a copy of dave's new
book baby steps millionaires because
that's your next step and you unless you
give it all away because you're a giving
guy we're also going to give you a copy
of the total money makeover for you to
hand to somebody else as they begin
their journey someone's going to come up
to you in the next month and say man i'm
struggling you're going to say i've got
it hang on and you're going to be able
to give them this book we are so proud
of you my brother you're a great human
being thank you for your service and
thank you for your
you're going to celebrate this by giving
it away which is just extraordinary all
right we've got jeff from sumter south
carolina paid off thirty thousand
dollars his mortgage he's a weird man
in one year count him down jeff let's do
hear your debt free scream
three two one i'm totally debt free
yeah
[Music]
i i'm trying to do the math in my head
ken
i think he had rice and beans once a
week oh yeah and we tried to crack him
he wasn't going to tell us none all we
know is that he's never eating bologna
again but i think he likes the rice and
beans is what i took away from it and if
you ever doubt the heart and mind of our
service men and women yeah that means
discipline to shut it shut it down and
be disciplined and accomplish a goal in
a short period of time
incredible if you're driving along and
you think i'm gonna have this stupid
mortgage forever
you don't have to
you don't
have to
get after it get after it and get it
done we'll be right back on the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go out to toronto canada and talk
to shanice shanice what's going on
hi guys it's great to talk to you it's
great to talk to you what's going on
um okay i'm really nervous so forgive me
if i don't make a lot of sense i'm gonna
try my best um just a little background
about me i am 29 i'm married i have a
child
and um i have been struggling with
starting or wanting to start a business
so i've wanted to start a business
forever
but i always feel like there's always
something that i always have to put in
front of that and focus on
and the biggest thing that i'm
struggling right now is just like the
fear and then also like struggling to
just kind of stay in my comfort zone and
not put myself out there
um and yeah i was just curious if you
guys had any advice to kind of like you
know get going because
you know one day i really like i'm
dreaming about having that that um that
call that tells you guys like we've paid
off our mortgage kind of thing so sure
so here's what i want to focus on first
i want to focus on specifically what
you're afraid of
what are you afraid of i want you to be
very specific
um i think the biggest thing that comes
to mind is definitely just putting
myself out there i would call myself
more of an introvert so i definitely
feel
more comfortable just being in my own
head in my own thoughts but um what's
the business i think
uh so i do fashion illustration and just
like illustrations in general but
um i've struggled to even put like my
work out there because i'm really afraid
of like people's opinions sure so
i'll get to that in a second and john
john as a psychologist i'm sure can go
even deeper but i'm just curious who
pays
who would pay you uh for that kind of
work where is that coming from
um so
when i've researched it um like you
could have you know women who just like
having like nice illustrations
as artwork maybe in their home
um or something like that but i also
know that uh there will be like large
corporations like in the fashion
industry or not necessarily in the
fashion industry that will use that for
like campaign work okay um and things
along that nature all right and so the
dream business for you i don't want you
to get too hung up on this but what's
the dream look like who are you who are
you doing it for is it full time what's
what kind of money are you making give
me that dream
um oh it's kind of embarrassing to say i
guess like no it's not a dream
the dream business would be doing that
full-time some capacity
or being able to have like a
product-based business that like i could
sell
um
you know like things to women goods to
women that make them feel good about
themselves and feel happy gotcha now
this goods these goods to women that's
that's another creative venture that's
not just illustrations that's you
creating something with your hands true
or false
that's true okay here's what i want to
ask you when was the last time you
showed anybody i don't even care if it's
your husband was the last time you
showed anybody some of your
illustrations or your crafts
uh it was definitely my husband and it
was probably like two weeks ago and
you've showed nobody else no other
friends
no acquaintance okay
um so i'm gonna i'm gonna pass it to my
pal who's a psychologist and dig into
the why
but i here's a challenge i've got for
you okay okay
at some point you have to determine
whether or not
this is gonna be a dream or a nightmare
and it's going to become a nightmare for
you if you never do it
so at some point you're going to have to
put yourself out there which means face
rejection
and here's what i want you to do i have
two homework assignments for you and
i'll give it to john
one homework assignment is is i want you
to actually
release show a craft or an illustration
on social media that you're already on i
want you just put it out there just put
it out there and just let people do what
they're gonna do with it it has nothing
to do with how great it looks or what
they're going to say i just want you to
put it out there and just see what
happens okay that's homework assignment
number one homework assignment number
two
i want you to research or reconnect
with the story the biography or just the
story that you're aware of of a designer
that you admire
and i want you to just dig in
become an expert in their story and find
out how much they dealt with rejection
and failure that's what i want you to do
so shanice um i'm not a psychologist but
i'm i'm a nerd i'm a nerd on the radio
um what
who has told you that you
your your work is garbage
um
no one specifically has ever told me my
work is garbage
who's ever told you that you're garbage
uh
no one no one specifically has ever said
those words to me but just definitely
situations i've been in where i've
failed have made me feel like that
so you're carrying around a story
that your failure at a thing
whether it's dodgeball or volleyball or
mowing a yard or or painting
equates to
you are a failure
yeah i guess so
what i want you to do is set that story
down because that story is inaccurate
it's weighing on you like a brick and
you're carrying around with you
everywhere and it it weighs on your
marriage it weighs on your son and most
importantly it weighs on you
and it's robbing it's robbing people in
our community in our world it's robbing
them of your art of your connectivity of
your gifts
you hear what i'm saying
the way you've to go through
take challenging these stories that you
carry around with you is i want you to
get a small little journal a small
little book you can spend 99 cents at
walmart or you can go overpay on etsy
for some fancy leather journal or
whatever but i want you to begin to
write down these stories
i failed at this
and no one's ever gonna love my work
i failed at this one time i screwed this
up and and i want you to write these
stories down however nonsensical they
are i want you to get them out of your
head and onto paper get them out of your
body so you can look at them and then i
want you to demand evidence from them
is this true
is the fact that this thing that this
person told me when i was 13 does that
really am i really a bad mom the answer
to that would be no
am i really not worthy of putting my art
out there the answer to that would be no
right but you can only do that for
yourself and if it gets hard and heavy
if you've got past trauma to deal with
then go get a counselor and walk along
to walk alongside you but when you start
challenging those stories you then get
to hold the pen and stop trying to edit
crap that's happened in your past but
you get to write something new what
comes next and then what ken said is
perfect
it the it's the it's aversion therapy
right it's it's you're going to do
something that scares you to death and
you're going to post a picture
and then you're going to find out that
it doesn't kill you
even if everybody hates it you're going
to find out oh gosh my husband still
loves me my kid still loves me my
heart's still beating am i right yeah
right and they're not going to all hate
it by the way they're going to love it
here's a question
let's just ask you a general success
question this is your opinion okay
there's no right or wrong answer because
this is your opinion
do you think
it is possible to move forward in any
venture of life without failure
uh no
i don't think so so then why in the
world are you holding yourself to a
standard that you don't even think
exists
you just said
it's impossible
to move forward
in any area of life whether you're
learning a sport an instrument
you're in class learning a topic a
subject
you're in business school whatever you
said you agree that it is impossible to
move forward without failure and yet
you're holding yourself to that
i guess it just it feels safer yeah it
does you know why because we all hate
the sting of rejection it goes back to
elementary school john when we wrote
these notes do you like me yes no or
maybe and we sat there in anticipation
waiting to see do they like us you
remember that shanice
yeah i do all right then
rejection is part of the deal
it's the price of admission
and your designs
and your crafts
will speak to certain women and you just
got to put it out there
do you believe us
yes i do all right
i screwed up it's not aversion therapy
it's exposure therapy i want you to
google it and i want you to challenge
yourself i want you to challenge
yourself okay google exposure therapy
and make sure you put therapy at the
other end of that of that google search
right or just do what i told you to do
and who cares what it's called there you
go there you go i want to make sure i'm
telling people to write things here all
right we'll be right back that's another
hour in the books thanks to ken coleman
and the gang in the booth james and
kelly we'll be right back on the ramsay
show
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
thermzyshow.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life your work your
relationships and mental health and your
money
i am john deloney joined here by
best-selling author and good friend ken
coleman and we are taking your calls on
just about anything triple eight eight
two five five two two five kelly's here
to take your calls and we will get you
on the air let's go to jerry in phoenix
arizona hey jerry what's going on my
brother
hey guys good to talk with you both you
too what's up
so i recently started a new job in the
i guess job realm that i would love to
be in
it's an incredible job so far but i feel
slightly underqualified
just because i never did like any formal
schooling for it and so i'm wondering
if
if i'm already in the space that i want
to be in would it still be an efficient
use of time to go back and actually get
a four-year college degree or
go into
getting certifications and things i'm in
the i.t world if i should just
specialize right away
specialize you don't need a degree
you're already in the field and many
times people feel that the degree is the
ticket in and in the technology world
this is increasingly not the case and so
you're already in now the specialized
is the key word the specialized
certifications and qualifications that's
what you need
and the fact that you're already in
makes you even more valuable immediately
because
many times they'll pay for it if they go
okay jerry's gonna stay with us if we
pay for his qualifications i'd start
looking at all those opportunities but
um it's simple if college
and a degree doesn't
get you where you want to go it's not
the only way then why in the world would
you do it and i think you've already
seen that that's the case
yeah yeah that makes sense um i
i still felt like uh you know there are
probably just some external pressures
saying you know what you are worth less
because you don't have a college degree
wait a second and i think
what says that who's who said that and
so who are the external pressures
well i would say it's not necessarily
like from a
as a person you're worthless i just
think that there have been like several
studies on
or potential earnings over a lifetime
for people that have college degrees
versus don't
but you know some of those studies may
be outdated well no
though i look at that stuff every day as
a part of what i do on the ken coleman
show so there's no question that when
you compare
um uh people who don't have a degree
people have a degree
that that's the case those studies are
relevant but but we're not talking about
that's a wide open field and understand
that field of study and those those
those that research shows the high and
the low but we're talking about you and
technology and i'm challenging you uh to
find any evidence that says you need a
degree to go where you want to go in
technology
have you found that
no i haven't because it doesn't exist
not in technology
not a technology now listen if you're
gonna be a doctor or a lawyer or a
physicist and i could keep going all
chemist and on and on and on and on and
on then yes you have to have a four-year
degree and then a higher education
degree but not in technology this is let
me tell you where this whole call
started out
the first thing i heard that is really
the source of your call is that you got
in the field and you said i feel
under qualified do you remember saying
that yeah your feeling
has no factual evidence to support it
would you agree with that
um
i would agree with most of that yeah all
right then
who has told you
otherwise has your new boss said you've
got no business being here or your new
co-worker says i can't believe they let
you in here
no i i think it's it's probably
internal monologue saying that because
there's just a lot that i don't know and
don't understand yet
hold on i'm all
confident that i can learn yeah there we
go jerry you're not under qualified for
what you're doing now you feel like
you're under qualified for what you want
to do is that what's going on
yeah that's
that's a much better way of putting it i
see why you do this for a living right
well but here's the point so i'm going
to go back to what i said i was right
all the way not something
so okay because here's why jerry
absolutely your boss thinks you're
qualified for the gig you got now so you
are you're not qualified for what you
want to do no big deal i can go get
qualified for what i want to do go do
that and stop thinking that you're an
imposter
and so at ramsey solutions we hire
different
sorts of technology folks and we've even
gone to sending our own people through
different training certifications to
increase like you know ruby on rails or
different different uh programming
languages and things like that there's
always certificates and things you can
level up with sometimes your your
employer will even pay for those if you
show an interest and want to learn that
stuff right or you can do it online by
yourself at night and learn these
languages or you can just tinker around
and work and work and chip away at it
and learn them yourself but that's about
you grinding it out that's not you
having some kind of magical
pixie dust certificate that you can wave
around and say look i've got value i've
got value brother you're in the door now
you got to work and crank it out and do
excellent work and be someone that's fun
to hang around with and then your
value's going to go to speak for itself
that's right you don't need a degree for
status jerry stop chasing status
you're significant man you're
significant do you hear me
yeah yeah you got talent man
you love technology work you care about
the missional result of the work that
makes you significant nobody gives a
crap about where you went to school i
love technology remember that yeah
that's a great movie all right it's time
to put 2021 behind us last year left a
lot of people feeling burned out and
sluggish eeyore was their spirit animal
but 2022 is a fresh start and this is
your wake-up call if you're ready to own
this year and actually accomplish your
goals with money your career and life we
have the plan to get you there you can
make 2022 your best year yet despite
what all the nonsense on the news is
telling you we're running our new year
sale right now so you can get up to 73
off our best-selling books assessments
and envelopes this includes dave's brand
new book baby steps millionaires that
will show you the quickest right way to
become a millionaire or if you're
looking for a better way to manage your
cash especially in categories always
that always blow up your budget like
food pick up our popular essential cash
envelope systems maybe you're having a
hard time bouncing back from the last
two wild years you should start 2022 by
checking out my quick read redefining
anxiety or if you're ready to move
careers check out ken coleman's from
paycheck to purpose the point is we got
books for everybody going through
everything
go to our online store at
ramseysolutions.com
backslash store to get serious and make
real progress but hurry the sale ends
soon
ken how many people do you talk to on a
weekly basis
that have it all lined up
and they are the ones standing in their
own way
uh it's about 50 of the calls because
people are calling in many ways just to
say here's what i'm thinking or feeling
here's what i'm doing ken do you think
i'm off my rocker or should i do it they
looking for permission it's all fear and
doubt and pride it's one of those three
enemies fear
doubt or pride always those are the
enemies of progress
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five i'm john delony joined with by ken
coleman and we are taking your calls on
life work money anything and everything
let's go to jessica in kansas city
kansas hey jessica what's going on
[Music]
hi thank you guys so much for taking my
call of course thanks for calling what's
up
so um my husband and i are
kind of on baby step three i say kind of
because
um we actually we actually hit
um three months of expenses saved today
um so we've got that and have kind of
settled that
we're okay with that um however i think
i call i call bull crap on that you're
not okay with it
i'm not well so i think that we're gonna
have to like re-level our home our car
is gonna break down and we're gonna like
lose our jobs all in one day which is
probably unrealistic
but
um jessica
you are my sister you are my sister in
spirit i am with you for sure
ken and i will go to dinner and it's
like ken you know it's all coming down
right dude you yeah i am with you i'm
with you but hey i want to go all the
way back you said
we're good with it i could tell in your
voice he's good with it you're not is
that is that accurate right okay so it
so it sounds so exciting to be like
we're on baby step four realistically we
could pretty much invest fifteen percent
of our household income unscathed um
with putting it into retirement and then
that would be really cool to be like
okay well now we're on baby step five um
but
i just
do i did we move on and three months is
good and then every you know little
surprise we just put a little bit more
in
our emergency fund or do we say hey
let's just stick it out for another
half a year and put the extra three
months in and then
um move on or
kind of write in the i don't know so
you're i need advice you're asking two
questions
one is a math problem
and one is an existential issue
the math problem is simple how how much
do you all make
what's your total um
yeah so
um taxes taken out we make about 80 000.
80 000.
and you owe no money except on your
mortgage how much is your mortgage
um our mortgage we just got our home
recently and so we owe
um about 200 000 on it okay
and how old are you two
i'm 24 and my husband's 25. and what do
y'all do for a living
i'm in healthcare marketing and he works
for um a university as a graduation
advisor and then i also have a part-time
job that i love so kind of everything
and
so when i'm looking at the math here
you've got three months of
emergency fund saved up you owe nobody
any money you'll make about 80 grand a
year and both of you are relatively you
you might not as much as him but he's
got a lot of places to grow
professionally right he's not going to
be a graduate advisor forever is that
right
right right yeah and you're i don't know
where you are in your career but you've
got places to go you've got a very
reasonable mortgage here
so math wise three months sounds fine
are your cars falling apart are they all
gonna
the wheels gonna fall off of them all at
the same time
um no mine can stick it out pretty well
and my husband is fairly reliable but
probably only has a few more years left
on it all right so when in doubt we
could go down to one card pretty easily
all right so i i think john's right i i
existential is a fancy word i just think
this is a relationship communication
problem i'm just curious how
is he just like i want to start baby
step four right now investing 15 he's
like gung-ho he's ready to start seeing
some roi is that what's going on how how
passionate is he on moving to step four
on a scale of one to ten mean one
doesn't care 10 he's charging the gates
of hell with a water pistol where is he
at
he's he's probably like a two he could
he could probably stay in babysit three
for a while i knew it okay well this
isn't this isn't that big of a problem
the problem's not been him ever just
what's in her head okay you want to go
to baby step four and you don't feel
safe why don't you feel safe
um you know i think it's because i have
always felt like i need to do everything
like i need to save but invest in
retirement and invest vest elsewhere
and
i like put i want to put my hands in
like five baskets at once instead of
focusing on one and moving on i have a
question
jessica
do you really think your fear of all the
bad stuff happening is gonna go away
with three more months savings
i feel like yes but probably not i think
the second part's true now
dave came up with these baby steps
if he were on here i think he would say
we say three to six months based on your
tolerance for
concern and worry and fear there's no
right or wrong answer
but you've got to engage with what's
really going on with you and it's that
you and john are exactly like i'll never
forget going to a great lunch with john
and his wife sheila and my wife stacy
and it was hilarious in in a 30-minute
lunch i think four times she rolled her
eyes at you because you basically were
chicken little like the worst possible
scenario could happen my wife speak to
this lady sheila was like john so i
think that's what's going on if you want
to do six months and it makes you feel
better great i'm not sure that's going
to solve the problem so jessica here's
how i handle this okay
number one i'm always looking to solve
for safety within reason
so if another three months makes you
feel better you're talking about what
six thousand bucks seven thousand bucks
um
uh
well
yeah i well so my version like i say my
version
six or seven thousand four dollars
well so we try like i attribute like 6
500
for a month like as if our life cannot
change all right so you want to get
about 15 or 18 20 000 more dollars in
that account all right if that makes you
like you will breathe
fine
but the
ken was alluding to there's another step
here and i'm gonna say this publicly i
don't talk about it a lot
i actually carry in my backpack
my awesome goruck backpack that i can
carry around hundreds of pounds in i
have a small little notebook that i
carry
and i wish there was another name that
wasn't so cheesy but this is what it is
it's my stories journal and i write down
crap that comes into my head
to make sure i can get it out of my head
and look at it objectively
because i will spin up sometimes i'll
get frustrated sometimes i'll think it's
all coming down sometimes and if i don't
address it right away if i don't take
action to control my thoughts i will end
up in a mountain of gummy candies trying
to call somebody to go get a drink and
hey right right it just spins out on me
and so
what i want you to do is to begin to
carry something and i uh call her in a
previous hour i told him you can go to
walmart and get something for 99 cents
or you can overpay for something on etsy
and get some fancy artist i don't care
what it is
but carry something around with you can
use your notes app on your phone
but i want you to begin to write down
these it's all coming down catastrophes
this is the end of time we're going to
have i want you to begin to write that
down and i literally want you to hold it
at arm's length and i want you to do one
thing demand evidence is this true
and what you're going to find is the the
more you solve for safety if you don't
deal with those stories your your
anxiety will move on you and it will
move again and it will move again and
suddenly oh he's answering the phone
it's probably some other woman and oh my
kids coughing oh no it must be right
you're just going to keep moving the bar
until you deal with those stories
and when you look at them objectively
you get them outside and you say is this
true and you go no
then you can begin to write something
new
i am safe i have six months emergency
fund brain thank you for trying to take
care of me but i'm good
does that sound more peaceful
it does yes thank you and listen jessica
practically speaking
i think i can speak for everybody that's
walking the baby steps out
when you get that emergency fund fully
funded it still sucks when you have to
use it oh you don't want to use it but
guess what you do
that's what it's for you replenish it
yeah the mercy fund is there for you to
not have an actual emergency because
financially you're able to take care of
it guess what you refund it and life
just keeps on going but can we
acknowledge
it's the worst to work that hard for a
fun like that you have to dip into it
but that's worse there it's the worst
yes and you won't feel like there's no
parade there's no things that fall from
the sky when you go to baby step four
that's right so if you need to feel safe
and fully fund your emergency fund great
but you stop at month six and start
investing
got it and then address those stories
that are haunting you you are worth a
good night sleep we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
eight two five five two two five let's
go to abe in sacramento hey abe what is
going on my brother
hey guys thanks for taking my call you
got it man how we how can we help
so uh i'm thinking about buying a new
truck and uh
i'm just trying to uh rush to make sure
it's a good decision
uh i don't owe any money to anybody paid
off my house about three four years ago
i have the money to pay cash but it's
just it's forty five thousand dollars
and uh
last time i purchased a new car
i said i'm never buying a new car again
uh
so i'm just trying to see if he makes
sense and uh trying to to make sense of
all this
what kind of truck is it
uh that's a coma
that's a great truck man what um what's
your annual salary
so fast our
household is about 120.
okay
so you got no debt you got no house
payment normally
i i don't want you spending more than
half your s your take-home pay on
vehicles anything with wheels on it okay
so this falls underneath that a new
truck is just expensive right now what i
would tell you is
man the difference between a 20 and a 22
what are we talking financially is it
five thousand ten thousand
or the uh
the bonkers
now
exactly there's not gonna be uh so i'm
actually getting a good deal on a new
truck uh a two three year old truck i
can probably buy for on the same money
uh from a dealership
so it's just uh
it's not a lot of difference any other
time
yeah any other time i tell you
because dave's rule of thumb is don't
buy a car unless you have a million
dollars i
buying new cars i just always think
that's just a dumb idea unless you're
just swimming in cash in this current
weird moment based on your economic
situation i don't have any problem with
it what's your hesitation
it's just a lot of money you know yeah
for that money it's just uh hard to just
uh write a check and drive away so so
okay so i want to lean in on this john
yeah let's let's the three of us do this
together abe
i love that john asked you that you
called us
and you basically are like john ken
should i buy this truck you got no debt
you got the cash
you know opinions can vary on this issue
that's not what's going on
i think in your heart of hearts you
wanted us to tell you not to do it is
that true or false i don't mind if i'm
wrong
i kind of wanted the other way around
i kind of knew i knew all the rules you
know the 50 so i kind of wanted to hear
from you guys to say you know what go go
splurge a little bit oh okay well john
did he gave me that but but but i got to
tell you something i
i still think you feel bad about it and
i think you got to come to grips with
that because you're going yup uh man 45
000 that's a lot of money i could do
something with it so then you have to
sit there and ask yourself
what matters most i think the
permissions are there i think john
already answered it you got what you
wanted
i just think this is
significant enough
for you to sit there and go all right
what if
i bought a five-year-old toyota and
let's say i spent 35 and i got 10 grand
what would i do with the 10 grand i
think you just should play it out
there's no right or wrong i'm with you
but i actually want you to wrestle with
this a little bit more because i think
that's what's really going on and i
think you got to feel good about this
yourself not get permission from two
dudes you don't know
why do you want a new truck
uh well i forgot to tell you guys this i
already have a truck i have a 2011 so
you know i plan to sell that hey believe
it
yeah that would have been nice to know
how much is that how much you gonna get
for
that yeah probably about 20.
hang up the phone and go buy a truck buy
the truck because you're getting 20 from
the one car and you're only putting 25
in and then come up with something cool
with the 20. give it away do something
cool
dude how old are you abe
38. when's the last time you did
again i i am as cheap as they come
when's the last time you did something
nice for yourself
you know that's why they call me squeaky
abe go buy a truck dude done go buy a
truck sleep well i thought he was coming
out of pocket 45. he's only going to
come out 25 after he sells that truck
all right let's go to garrison in
gulfport mississippi what's up garrison
hello
what's up
can you hear me yes sir
awesome well first off i appreciate
everything y'all do i'm talking about
two favorite people in the world right
now oh wow that's nice you gotta get
better people in your life
well i just now hit uh baby step 2 about
a week ago
and my new year's resolution was to you
know be more financially stable and to
get myself out of debt and be
provided well for my family and um
i'm not seeing eye to eye with my fiance
i just found out on christmas eve that
we are expecting our third baby
um
and every time i bring up the budget and
wanted to do it with her
she just keeps blowing it off
and i want us to pay off her bed but
she's just not seeing eye to eye with it
and i've been listening to your podcast
i'm listening to the john daloni show
the randy show and the ken coleman show
for the last six months i'm a truck
driver
and i love everything y'all do so i was
just trying to reach out and see if
y'all could help me out
so first thing congratulations on number
three how old are your other two
uh my son is five and my daughter just
turned one this month when are you
getting married
um
see she
she's not ready yet she told me recently
she does not want to get married till
she gets
uh excuse my language a
food job
okay you've got
you're about to have your third kid
the the she's not ready yet that that
doesn't compute for me but that's a
different call you can call one of our
shows and we'll talk about that
so when it comes to getting people on
board
usually
somebody's coming at somebody with
either a bunch of you need to do this
you need to do that right away or
they're coming at them with a math
problem
if we just do this we can save this much
and then put this much away and neither
math problems nor
people barking orders at you are ever
compelling for long-term behavior change
what is
is sitting down and saying this is my
heart in this matter
i am i feel unsafe having three kids and
owing this kind of money
i feel like i am not providing for this
family because we are spending
tomorrow's money on last month's food
let me let me jump in garrison um
there's a relationship issue that john's
alluding to this is a whole nother onion
in this phone call but we have to
address this for a second
there is no we right now you guys aren't
married i'm assuming you don't have sep
you have separate accounts or do you
guys join accounts you're paying each
other's debts what's going on what does
it look like so
so um i've recently i'm a truck driver
i'm out on the road so i put her on my
account but then she still has her own
account with
um her job that she does okay what my
point is is you have debts and she has
debts correct
yes sir okay you need to be addressing
your debts
and she does not need to be in your bank
account
if you guys aren't married
and i'm not questioning her i'm not
trying to take us down that road of why
she's not ready but i'm just telling you
to protect yourself john i thought use
the right word here i mean you are these
child you're you're the father of these
children but you guys aren't married and
you need to take care of your debt we're
talking about legal
legally right and hey garrison
i i don't want to be the first guy to
tell you this but here we go
a breast enhancement surgery is not a
reason to not get married
there's something else here
am i right
yeah i think i think there is you know i
i don't know if it's hard for her me
being out on the road this whole time
and being so far away i'm i'm not sure
it's enough that she keeps having
children with you but not enough that
she has said i want to get married
your relationship y'all are
this is one of those i'm going to flip
the lights on turn the music off and say
hey we got to stop the party yeah
something's not right here yeah
i heard you say that before yep and
you're there now okay garrison take care
of you dude yes and those three little
babies take care of your relationship
but there's some there's some dishonesty
there there's some there's some mess
here going on and you need to get to the
bottom of it
uh but when it comes to
taking care of your money you know what
all this ken you're right this is all a
relationship issue y'all are not on the
same page at all in any way and you got
you're making humans together yeah you
got to get on the same page today
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free with free
samples free shipping and with the new
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use promo code ramsey to get
the best deal rules and restrictions
apply today's question comes from ashley
in minnesota after eight years in
college
my husband is graduating soon with a
degree in chemical engineering we
currently live with my dad and his his
parents support my husband when he needs
money he has a great internship that
will most likely turn into a full-time
job he doesn't hate the job but now he's
saying engineering isn't
fulfilling and he wants to go into law
enforcement i don't want him to do this
for many reasons but mostly i don't want
him to do this because we literally
can't afford to live
off of what a police officer would earn
i don't want to have to choose between
paying our mortgage in a car payment
or a car payment he acts like i'm the
bad guy because i encouraged him to go
into chemical engineering he doesn't
seem to understand paying bills isn't
optional i'm tired of always being the
adult in this situation should my
husband start a career that won't allow
us to pay our bills when he has a great
job lined up and this is exhibit a john
whoa of a of a relationship question
disguised
as a career question i
that's not a career question you know it
and i know it and it's like sweetheart
there's so much passive aggression and
irritation dripping off of this john i
can't answer that you know that's not a
career question no
you
that's you that's a relationship can we
just break this down can we spend a
little bit on this there's a lot in this
all right yeah go this is good
after eight years in college yeah my
husband's graduating with a degree in
chemical engineering
you could already feel the disdain over
the eight years yes so my husband's dumb
and lazy okay right we currently live
with my dad yeah and his parents support
my husband when he needs money
more resentment so we're living with my
parents yeah my dad but his parents are
paying our bills uh-huh he has a great
internship that will most likely turn
into a full-time job
he didn't hate it
but now he says he's not fulfilled he
wants to go to law enforcement ashley
this is an email of somebody who's about
to file for divorce yep that's what this
is yeah and so should my husband start a
career that won't allow us to pay our
bills when he has a great job lined up
is not the question the question is are
we going to be married this time next
year yeah that's where you start because
this this email sounds a lot
like you resent him
and not a lot of relationships come back
from resentment that's usually when
things are in ash this is this is
marriage counseling
heart to heart hey here's here's what i
want from you and you've not provided it
she doesn't feel safe with this guy
right and he doesn't feel he blames her
he blames
losing a decade of his life studying
something he didn't want to in the first
place yeah these two are just they're
they're on opposite sides it's like it's
like the old school revolutionary war
movies where you know they fought this
way yeah they just the british and the
americans line up together and they look
at each other and they shoot each other
point blank
this this is what this relationship is
it feels like it's back and forth back
and forth they're not even on the same
side and all they're doing is firing at
each other close range that's right and
for what it's worth i grew up in the
home of a police officer and we did not
have a lot
but we never missed a meal yeah
yeah i think that's what i mean you know
i'm glad you pointed out because it was
she's got a false narrative she's got a
false narrative that's right you can
make a nice living i mean certainly now
it's hard it is hard it's hard we don't
pay police officers enough that's true
but um i grew up in this house it was
hard but we made it and so this uh it's
all good
that's not it you're mad at your husband
you're frustrated with him you're done
with him actually and you all need to
get to a marriage counselor asap
all right let's go to dan in boise idaho
what's up brother dan
hey how's it going guys good how are you
taking my call you got it what's up good
hey um so i'm in a job where i get calls
a lot
a lot of different customers a lot of
clients a lot of just random people and
i have a very difficult time
prioritizing who i should get to first
because every in my line of work
everything's an emergency
so
when i get a long list of things that i
feel like i need to do it just kind of
shuts me down okay it just it just
makes it difficult for me to
focus on one thing and do that one thing
then move to the next week even though i
know that's what i should do and then i
end up doing nothing
and
it's and then catching up you know
the next day or at night or something
like that what is your position
um i do uh commercial um hvac sales so
you are a salesperson of hvac systems
correct
correct yeah right and you have a pretty
good idea i'm not gonna make you say it
on the air but you have a pretty good
idea what your job description is
correct
yeah okay
uh were you at some point
not not right now as you're presenting
but were you at some point pretty clear
on what is expected of you as a
salesperson of hvac systems
um
it's not a trick question
you were okay let me ask you what when
you were hired to be a salesperson of
hvac systems what is your number one
priority dan
well it would be to sell system to just
to sell systems but i look at it as
providing good customer service to my
clients i don't necessarily look at it
as my goal it's just to sell
x amount of systems i agree but i'm
trying to help you process all this
confusion you feel confused because
you're getting so many different
requests
and you're like i'm having a hard time
prioritizing and i'm trying to help you
see what matters most
so what is if i was talking to your boss
right now what would your boss say your
priority is
probably probably just the sales partner
okay
of course so give me an example of the
type of calls that are coming in
that are paralyzing you
that aren't related to selling
so i get a lot of calls from clients
with little needs
and then i feel like i have to take care
of needs that are not related to sales
give me an example
give me an example um so i have a
customer called in says they have a
thermostat problem
and
they have a it's a minor problem that a
service deck could probably take care of
well i know that all our service types
are really busy right now
so i feel like i need to stop everything
help this person real quick and then i
can move on
and except
that's not what happens
no
right
but dan
what happens if you out of the goodness
of your heart are always handling those
requests
and then it starts to cut into your
sales dan what's going to happen
yeah it hasn't happened yet i didn't
wait a second
you don't get to answer a different
question you have to answer the question
that i asked what happened
if your sales start to drop
i make less and i'm giving them my you
know fear and my doubt that i'm always
gonna fail sometimes you know in the
future
so you might it's possible you could
lose your job
too yeah that's pretty that's not going
to happen
confident
oh i like this we went from doubting dan
to they're not going to get rid of me
okay look i'll i'll pass the baton to my
to my partner but let me just say this
dan
you're going to have to start to get
over
this people pleasing which is a messiah
complex
yeah you've got some massive stuff going
on here and the reality is you got to do
what you know you're supposed to do so
i'll leave it to john
on the counseling side but you know what
you're supposed to do start doing it
here's my question do you like helping
people more than you like selling dan
do you like taking care of knickknacks
and taking care of the people that
you're serving more than cold calling
somebody
oh absolutely
okay
you don't like your job so go do
something where you can do customer
service all day
or or yeah stop trying to be the messiah
and save everybody and pass these on to
the technicians because that's their job
and if they don't do their job in a
timely fashion and respectable dignified
fashion then you go to the owner or the
ceo or you're operating chain of command
and you say i'm trying to love and honor
my clients and my customers and these
guys on my team will not get the work
done
but you trying to circumvent the system
and be everything to everybody is giving
you a free pass on the hard part of your
job which is out actually selling units
is that fair yeah
yeah solicit fair dan you have to decide
do you want to be a customer service
rep do you want to be a technician or do
you want to be a salesperson it's time
to be an adult you got this decide
and then stop doing other people's jobs
go do yours just do yours go watch
frozen there's a great little theme song
on that called let it go
don't hold it back anymore hey ken good
show james childs kelly daniels as
always y'all are beautiful and handsome
and brilliant another hour in the books
we'll be right back on the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsey show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your money your life
your relationships your work your mental
health anything and everything give us a
shout triple eight eight two five five
two two five i'm john deloney joined by
good friend and best-selling author ken
coleman we are taking your calls on work
and life and money we're here for you
aaa 825-5225
let's go to matt in tulsa oklahoma hey
matt what's going on
how's it going guys good how are you
brother
oh doing good so far i think so thanks
for having me on of course thanks for
calling i
i've been searching through you guys
episodes previous and past and i can't
find an answer to a question that i have
i'm almost done with baby step two
um in march i'll be 100 debt free except
for the fact that i rent still
at what point in time do i look at
buying a house like what step is that
it's a great question so let's back up a
little bit how much money do you make
so i currently make 67 000 a year 67
what do you do man
uh recruiter for the national award oh
very cool are you in the national guard
yourself
active very cool man thanks for your
service brother
um yeah y'all had last couple of years
haven't you
oh yeah it's been interesting
it's your ass well thanks for your
service
so you're finishing up baby step two
you're gonna be completely debt free in
a few months
and tell me about a house you want to
buy a house you like where you live or
are you just thinking i should be doing
this thing
no i just know that like with my budget
that i have because i use every dollar
app
um i could be saving a lot of money by
paying towards a mortgage instead of
rent i pay 700 a month in rent
when that could be going to something
that's not going to someone else's
pocket but i don't know what step that
is that i need to do that
gotcha how long is it going to take you
to get the uh baby step three three to
six months expenses
fully funded you have any idea
uh with my current budget um it'll take
around 60 days after i get done with
baby step two nice excellent so here's
what i want you to think about a couple
things number one i want to acknowledge
and i feel it
paying rent feels like when you're
paying rent that's 700 bucks and you can
go down the street and find a 1100
mortgage it feels like you're wasting
you know almost half more than half your
payment right
as a homeowner who just this past month
had to replace an air conditioning
system and i had to do some other work
on the house and i've got to replace the
hot water here what i'm telling you what
feels like it on the surface actually
isn't in the short term
so i want you to be completely debt free
i want you to have a fully funded
emergency fund and then i want you to
have saved up 10 to 20 just to get into
the house
and they're gonna for you especially
they're gonna have all kinds of veterans
programs they're gonna get you in for no
money down and all
it's not a good deal because you end up
getting into a house and you're
immediately upside down in it until you
can pay off enough to get some equity in
it that you would even be able to get
out and pay the realtor fees to move
so you're looking at a couple of years
from now unless you start getting some
unless you get a side hustle or two and
start just hammering it to save some
money but you're completely debt free
you got an emergency fund like buying a
new air conditioner it was not fun but
it wasn't catastrophic yeah it was super
annoying so i got an emergency fund we
paid for it it's annoying i'm gonna have
to save the money back up in the
emergency fund but i'm going on with my
life
so matt
the answer is we call it baby step 3b
over time we've developed in baby step 3
uh 3b which means after you get the
fully funded emergency fund then you
move into saving for the house that's
what that's what john is telling you i'm
just curious how how much house are you
looking to buy
so around here i can get a house for 112
i mean i'm a single guy i don't have any
kid
i can get a house a two-bedroom for
hundred and ten thousand dollars
so so we want you to get at least the 20
right we want you to do a 15-year
mortgage so that's your target there
do you understand what i'm saying
absolutely yeah so that's what baby step
3b is going to look like for you there
and then if you hit the gas on this
thing you're going to look up and it's
going to be
two years from now you'll have really
hustled you're going to get some cash
and you're going to save it up and you
might decide hey i'm going to move i
want to live in another community
i've got a significant other now that
wants does not want a two-bedroom house
but once so your things change a little
bit um matt how old are you brother
hey what i'm saying how old are you
uh 31 31 okay so
you've been at this for a while so
you're getting there and i get that um
can
you and stacy already when you first
moved to nashville right we ran in for
two years with three kids and we knew we
were going to be here
but we realized that with three kids
moving back into middle tennessee we
wanted to go all right let's take our
time and figure out the best place
because this is our long-term play right
and frankly we didn't we didn't have the
down payment that we wanted because we
took care of some other things and
and it was the best thing we could do
because it took the pressure off and i
think it's uh it's a shift for matt and
other people to go wait a second i'm not
throwing money out the door and wasting
it i'm not burning it every month
i would switch the mindset to what is it
buying me what is renting buying me to
your point
he could be pretty quickly in 60 days or
so he's gonna be you know uh debt free
and then working on the emergency fund
may be fully funded
and he could go right into baby step
four
and invest if he wanted to and if he's
serious about getting married then wait
to decide
you know on that double income or what
does she want to your point but if he
feels he's going to be single a while
and he really wants to be a homeowner
then we gave him that approach too but i
just think the mindset has to be what
does renting do for me oh so what if we
thought about rent not as just throwing
money out the window i've heard that
before but what if we looked at rent as
i'm buying freedom every month i'm
freedom from bills from catastrophes
for stacey and i peace of mind to figure
out what's the right school system
best neighborhood
location
i don't care here that's your that's the
landowner's job right yeah i i gotta
tell you it was very peaceful yeah i we
did the same thing and there is
definitely some peace and making sure
i'm buying the right house i can afford
to get in it and
i don't want to blow by that either
the house down payment is so important
because if you if you put no money down
on a house or just three percent down
to get out of the house you pay six
percent in realtor fees right so you
instantly lose money walking right out
the door right so at least give yourself
the opportunity to get out of your house
if you have to if something if you lose
your job or there's some kind of you
have to move whatever this is going on
save up that 10 to 20 and go into a
house as rachel says it's a blessing not
a curse yeah you know what was awesome
stacey and i we were debt free
okay when we moved here yep but we had
our house in atlanta we paid that off it
was nice to be truly no home payment no
house payment rent was rent yeah
it was like hey we're not going to be
here forever but it's a great place for
us to land right now it was so peaceful
so strategic so smart and it allowed us
the time to make a big gigantic decision
like buying a house right and maybe
that's my problem i
i tend to look at it like you yeah i
don't look like at it like i'm wasting
my life or because i've got other plans
and other ideas that can come down the
road but it's more about what can i do
right what's the best decision right now
yeah and renting just has this bad uh
there's a bad taste in people's mouth
but i just don't have i don't have i
don't have it either you're about two
years away brother matt and then you can
buy your two bedroom house or save up a
little bit more and buy yourself a more
long-term place to stay we'll be right
back on the ramsay show
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
this is the ramsay show triple eight
eight two five five two two five i'm
john doloni joined here by my good
friend ken coleman we're taking your
calls on money on life on relationships
on everything triple eight eight two
five five two two five
how would you feel if you knew you could
retire with dignity leave an inheritance
for your family it would be freeing
right the truth is you can have that
kind of life you can build wealth even
become a millionaire but it starts with
having the right habits it starts by
deciding here and now that you're ready
for real life change this year take
control of your money and start building
lasting wealth with the best year ever
bundle
in this bundle you will get access to
financial peace university and the
premium version of every dollar
two resources to help you take back
control of your biggest wealth building
tool your income
then you'll use the copy of dave's brand
new book baby steps millionaires to
learn the right way to invest and get to
a million dollar net worth look what you
do right now is impacting the kind of
life you'll have later the good news is
you get to decide what that life looks
like if you want to forever change your
family tree and forever change your life
get the best year ever bundle by
visiting ramsay solutions dot com slash
best that's ramsay solutions dot com
slash best let's go to jason in
nashville tennessee hey jason right down
the street what's up man
hey good afternoon gentlemen thank you
for taking my call you got it what's up
hey so my question for you so my my wife
and i are going to be in baby step 7
here in the next 12 to 18 months
congratulations you know
yes thank you we really appreciate all
the work that y'all do it's fantastic
and life-changing stuff so
we want to practice that insane
generosity so my question is how do we
become insanely generous with family and
friends without hurting the relationship
oh good question give me an example of
what you're thinking about
well we have family who you know are not
doing as well as us that we want to be
able to help and but we also don't want
to enable that behavior and we also you
know we don't want them to struggle
either you know because we love them
they're close to us so it's like how do
we be that example without being an
enabler
so
you want to be an example
and you don't want to enable what does
that have to do with giving money away
it really doesn't um and that's really
you know like i said i know there's been
situations where i've heard callers say
hey
you know i started giving money to
somebody and then that person started
treating me differently or
you know that it became different at
holidays you know the the dynamic of the
relationship changed which i mean i'm
sure it's inevitable i'm just curious
you know are there any tips that we
could approach that in a way that that
maintains that respect without being
overbearing or being you know insulting
in that situation have you ever met
somebody who discovered a keto diet for
the first time
a few yes
you ever met somebody who is a die-hard
vegan
oh yeah i was gonna say to the death but
actually to the opposite like vegan to
the plant right
whenever somebody starts changing the
way they eat and it feels good their
body feels good
and whether that's physiological or they
convince themselves of that
what do they always want to do
tell people about him yes
and i honor that if you've if you've
stumbled on something if my friend ken
coleman stumbles on something that makes
his life better i hope he will love me
enough to tell me about it i interrupt
him he's he i do this all the time
and
if he comes at me
with a bag of lettuce and and celery and
tries to shove it down my throat yeah or
if he melts butter in his coffee and
pours it all over me i'm gonna get
pissed right wow very descriptive you
see so the difference here is
you can model for your family life
change
you can walk alongside them you cannot
make them
live differently
by forcing stuff on them when it comes
to money and family
i believe
if you find somebody and they are they
are in dire straits they are struggling
can hop in here they're struggling
they're dying
i think it's okay to take somebody out
to breakfast and say are you doing okay
how can i love you better
if you come at him and say hey i know
you're broke here's 5 000 bucks that's
gonna change the relationship if you sit
down and say hey i love you how can i
help because they may need help
uh they may need some budgeting tips and
they may need a thousand dollars because
they're about to get their
lights and water cut off
down the road
being intentional about i'm gonna help
folks i'm gonna have relationships with
folks that they feel comfortable and
safe asking me for support and care i'm
not gonna run around and try to shove my
things down people's throat does that
make sense
yeah no that makes a lot of sense jason
i i think you're thinking of a family
member a very specific one or two is
that true
that's correct all right and so i want
to guard your privacy here um
let's be more specific
so you're thinking of a specific family
member and what were you thinking of
doing for them
you called us you already had an idea in
your mind and we've kind of been talking
around this thing generally i want to
get really detailed on this so so how
what were you thinking of doing for them
uh i mean some home repairs they have
some situations where you know if it's a
situation the house isn't fixed it's
going to cause a lot more uh problems
with a with a much bigger financial
liability
all right so what would be the out of
pocket to take care of those problems
that would
stay stay some major issues it would
really help avoid some major issues how
much money would it cost you to help
with those repairs
um probably five to eight thousand okay
and what were you worried about
happening
play this out in your mind you give them
the five to eight grand for the repairs
and you're worried that it was going to
enable them to keep doing stuff
or do you feel like they're going to be
beholden to you let's let's name this
i think it's more that
it's not going to encourage them to
improve themselves and i think that's
what worries me yeah they got some
destructive behaviors and all you're
going to do is save them a bunch of
money but it's really not going to
change things
correct
yeah i
the reason i'm digging into that john
very specifically is because i wanted to
know what's really going on here and i
think if you got some family members
that are doing some things that are
destructive
um
and that five to eight thousand dollars
while saving them a lot of money is it
going to do a whole lot i think that's
why you called you're questioning is
this a is this like spitting into the
wind is that what you're really
wrestling with
that's yes and i mean
i don't want to
i don't want to hurt the relationship i
want to still be you know i want to love
this person i want to be an example for
them and i don't want to create any
barriers by by being that that financial
you know support so all right so let's
dive into that you know who you're
talking about do you what do you think
the chances are if you were to walk in
and go hey i noticed all this stuff's
going on with the house if it doesn't
get fixed it's probably going to turn
into this and i've got some cash because
the way i've been living and i'd like to
pay for the repairs what are you worried
about happening
specifically um that i only hear from
them when something else breaks
then i think and given this john i'm
willing to be wrong yeah i think this is
a check that you need to honor i think
sometimes fear is lying to us and
sometimes fear is protecting us and i
think this is a fear going don't touch
the burner because if you do it burns
your hand i think you're worried about
getting burned and i think that it's
protecting you i think i'd listen to it
yeah i think you love them a different
way no i think i think you're right
the the one stipulation here so here's
where i personally get involved in a
situation like this
if we're dealing with adults i'm gonna
love my friends my family my community
members who are making different life
choices than me i'm gonna love them but
i'm not going to participate right if
they come to me for support and care and
help then that's a different story but
i'm not just going to jump in to try to
play savior
the times i will get involved
is when there are little children
involved
are there kids involved in an unsafe
home here jason
oh no that's not the case okay good so i
think i agree with ken man i think this
at best this starts with a lunch
and uh hey how's everything going not a
text exchange but hey i'd love to take
you all to lunch just check in see how
things are going
and start there and if they won't have a
conversation with you if they can't be
honest about things that are going on um
i i heard recently somebody of means say
if a family member asks for money i
don't borrow i don't loan it i give it
to them and then i say this is it
this is the time like this is your shot
right and so however you handle that is
fine i want to flip the conversation
around though
if somebody is really struggling and
they come to you for help
and you help them you have not
inherently screwed up that relationship
yeah
if you go chasing to solve everybody's
problems around you with your big fancy
money yeah you're causing the problem
but if somebody comes to you for help
and says hey i'm in it i'm in a hole and
i need some some support here
man
the relationship may be altered but that
one's not on you
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
so
[Music]
triple eight eight two five five two two
five this is the ramsey show let's go
out to doug in denver colorado hey doug
what's going on
hey what's going on gentlemen how are
you
good how are you excellent what's up how
can we help
hey so my main question is for ken i'm
trying to ask him
what professional advice he has for a 28
year old male who doesn't exactly know
what he wants to do right now
yeah well we just have to dive in and
see if that statement is 100 factually
correct
i just got to believe doug you called
today because you have some ideas and
you want some validation of the ideas do
you have any ideas you ever wondered
about what would i do if i knew i
couldn't fail or something you know
you've always wanted to do but you're
not quite sure how to get there what's
really going on
uh well right now i'm going to school
for computer science with a
specialization in i.t um i like i like
that idea because i can work from home
by myself if i chose to
it does get kind of boring though and i
guess if i had to choose a dream job
right now we would be teaching jiu-jitsu
because i'm really good at it and doing
that right now okay so wait a second how
much is a full-time
successful so uh you know whether you
own your own studio which is an option
that's an entrepreneurial play for sure
or you're working for an established
studio how much can a full-time
jiu-jitsu instructor make
um
it's okay if you don't know
yeah i mean
you don't know
yeah exactly yeah so are you part-time
right now is that what you're doing or
do you just compete for yourself what's
the deal
no i do it four or five days a week
for and uh somebody who owns their own
studio
no
who do you do for
uh i train under my instructor either
brown vote right but i mean is he paying
you who's paying you to do this no he's
he's saying he it's a hobby okay i
misunderstood all right i'm trying to
figure out this is what you would like
to do that would be the dream job so you
got to talk to your instructor and go
hey what's the path look like
you know how much money does he make you
know go talk to some people who run some
jiu jitsu studios
hey this is what we make this is what
our rent is i mean get a real snapshot
of what it looks like
you can't kind of have a dream you got
to have a dream and i feel like it's
kind of this
fun idea for you because you love it so
much but if you actually look into it
and see that there's a path forward and
it's possible would you if i told you
you could make good money and provide in
the jujitsu lane
right
would you choose that over technology
right now
yes sir absolutely so i want you to
actually figure out what does a career
look like what are the multiple options
i can work for somebody else as a high
level trainer or i can work for myself
uh you got to do your homework and
here's the good news
you are already in that world you have
all the relationships you need to get
those answers true or false
true all right now here's the other
option if you like a form of technology
work
then figure out okay what kind of
technology work would i enjoy and it
wouldn't be boring and i could work from
home but it would also allow me the
stability of a really great salary with
some promotional opportunities while i
build the jiu jitsu career so i want you
to consider both end depending on the
answers you get on what it's going to
take to get qualified and get connected
and get started and move up in the jiu
jitsu world so
this is the simple path forward makes
sense
yes sir yeah
well i appreciate the call when we don't
know
what the future could be
we stay stuck john it's like well i kind
of would like you know i mean dream job
could be jiu jitsu well we got to go
from could be that's curiosity we got to
really dive in
and then when we find out everything
there is to know about what a career
looks like in the jiu jitsu world
multiple lanes i'm sure
then it goes from could be to should be
then it goes from should be to must be
yeah as we explore and see what is it
going to take because he might go all
right
well
uh i could make x amount of money but if
i want to have a wife and kids that's
not going to pay for things so that's
why technology career
as a stable day job
could be the path first
and then we develop the jiu jitsu he
keeps training he gets his certification
he kind of gets in and then over time he
builds that side hustle up and one day
he steps off the dock from technology
into that he owns his own studio and
he's cash and he's not in debt for a
studio that that's the path that i'm
trying to help him see but you can only
see that when you dive in and ask the
questions what does it take to do this
full time
so what do you tell somebody
i find myself
i found myself in a similar situation i
was working at a university got a good
job it was stable
and then i would go spin two three
sometimes four hours in the jiu jitsu
studio myself yeah and there was a group
of guys and we worked hard a group of
men and women we worked hard we trained
hard we got after each other and there's
kickboxing so we were we were fighting a
lot and i loved it
and then i started thinking okay what
would it be like to man this would be
kind of cool and then i realized a
couple of things one i'm not that good
two it's kind of old three
this is more of a hobby yep than it is a
job and really what i was taking away is
i thought i really loved jiu jitsu i
really loved mma what i really loved i
did love the competition make no mistake
i love the camaraderie yes i love the
community
those those guys and gals became my gang
yeah right we hung out we went to
concerts so how do you help somebody
tease apart whether i need to go for
this thing full time or it's okay to
have a hobby to love shredding your
guitar being a chef
but you got a day job well a version of
what i told him which is he's got to go
sit down and it's just the exploration
yeah so i call that process that i just
walk dug through clarify and verify okay
so when i told him
talk to your instructor i told him you
know everybody you need to know in there
to find out what are the paths what are
full-time paid
paths
in jiu jitsu and if you run a one of
them obviously is a professional you're
not doing jiu jitsu all day you're doing
paperwork you're a small business owner
right you know who has to also either
train or hire trainers right so so
that's what i was telling him to do you
got to go figure out what does it look
like what does a day in the life look
like how much can you make how long does
it take to make that what are the risks
associated with starting the jujitsu
business
that's called clarify
and then john as we clarify
what is involved
how do you get there
risks
rewards all that your heart this is
where you and i really come together on
a lot of stuff your heart verifies right
clarify and verify so the heart will go
oh yeah i love i want to train
students which would be
retired folks
a elementary school kid who's been
bullied you have a heart for what
jiu-jitsu does for the person and you
want to instruct that that's a deep
passion now here's the deal you still
have to go do i want to do that all day
every day right and therein lies the
verify
profession or hobby yeah that's it okay
profession or participation gotcha
there's a big difference and i'm glad
you pointed out so clarify verify
i think john that when the brain does
its part the logical gathering of
information then the heart steps in and
does its part and says yeah i want to do
this all the time
or
thought i did i thought i did until i
realized oh this is 70 ordering and
marketing and i don't want to do that
cleaning mats i just really love jitsuit
i really love being around the gym yeah
that's great makes a great distinction
do that that's how you do it let the
heart and head work together gotcha very
cool
okay folks brace yourself tax season is
about here i know it's probably not your
favorite announcement but look any day
now you're going to start getting your
w-2s or 1099s from your employer and
this is not the year to procrastinate on
your taxes there are a couple of reasons
i say that first a lot happened in 2021
that could affect your taxes second the
irs is struggling shocker alert they're
dealing with a worker shortage plus a
massive backlog of unprocessed paper
returns and they're adapting to pandemic
related tax changes just like you so
even though it's hard to feel sorry for
the irs they've got a lot on their plate
and we're expecting it'll take them
longer to process returns if you're
comfortable filing online we have an
excellent budget friendly recommendation
it's called ramsey smart tax and most
people save 60 to 120 bucks when they
switch from the leading competitor this
is how i do my taxes at my kitchen table
on the other hand if your taxes seem too
complicated or the idea of filing taxes
by yourself freaks you out you don't
have to do them alone we have tax
professionals across the country who we
trust to serve you well and do your
taxes right we can put you in touch with
him today head over to
ramseysolutions.com tax to learn more go
to ramseysolutions.com
tax we'll be right back
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
today's scripture is isaiah 43 19.
see i am doing a new thing
now it springs up do you not perceive it
i am making a way in the wilderness and
streams in the wasteland
t.s eliot says only those who will risk
too far can possibly find out how far
one can go
outstanding let's go to jessica in
milwaukee hey jessica what's going on
hi um i have a six-year-old son with
adhd
and i'm wondering if it is age
appropriate to tell him
that he might
be kicked out of his school this year
okay so yeah let's separate those two
things real quick those are two separate
challenges here so what's going on at
school
um well he
is he's also actually high functioning
extremely high functioning autism
but
that doesn't seem to be causing a
concern at school but that allowed him
to get his own personal aid for school
now in this upcoming year
the
insurance won't be covering that aid
so
the school said that if he is disruptive
to the point that he needs to be removed
to the classroom frequently
that he would not be allowed to return
just because they don't have the extra
staff to
monitor him out in the hallway if he
needs to be removed if he gets
wound up is he at a private school or a
public school
it is private um i
yeah we went through the public um
we went through an iep for a little bit
there but they
didn't they deemed that he did not need
an aid at all
and
so we didn't feel comfortable with that
either at that time because we knew that
he needed that extra help we didn't want
him to fall behind
okay so we got kind of stuck when they
yeah i know that's a nightmare
the
when you you went through the iep
process did they provide a psychologist
evaluation or do you have to go get him
evaluated somewhere and then turn that
report in
um
they did as psychologists and that was
what that psychologist gave we didn't
like it so then we got a professional
and they're the ones that deemed that he
needed an aide okay so what i would do
is circle back
with that new report
it may be worth even going to an aba
specialist and getting a nut yet another
one an updated
um
review and a
updated evaluation and sitting down
right now with your public school
because here's the thing
telling a six-year-old that
here's what's about to happen to you
will not compute especially a
non-neurotypical six-year-old
and adhd is one thing
adhd plus autism is a whole other
situation
so telling him hey if you do this then
this is going to happen and then here's
going to be the downstream consequences
that may happen months from now is tough
for a neurotypical six six-year-old much
less one who's got got challenges
i want him to work on
immediate behaviors are you does he have
care uh in the care of a counselor he's
got a behavior specialist that he's
working with yes yes he has an aba
specialist
and um
occupational therapist as well has he
acted out before
um
it's honestly getting better great um in
my opinion but it's still just that fact
that the school might be the one to
determine and since he seems so on so
often i don't want if he can control it
it would be wonderful if he understood
the consequences because he did but if
he's not age appropriate to understand
it that's you know another story but he
did go to a preschool where he was
kicked out of and i just don't want him
to go through that pain again because he
didn't i we didn't tell him why
um and we didn't even tell him he was
kicked out he just asked why can't i go
back to that school and we just you know
so we just kind of told him oh lord
we're gonna try this school this time
and
i don't and he didn't like that he was
really sad so just if i can avoid it it
would be great
yeah i
i'm gonna speak as broadly as i can
because i'm gonna want to protect folks
in my own life
yes but i do not want my kids at a
school that does not want them
and for millions and millions and
millions of people who are stuck in a
local public school
that statement sounds trite and ugly and
i get that
but i tried a particular private school
and they said we don't want your kid
here
and
i then transitioned to a public school
and it has been life-changing
with the support the care and the love
some of it was just developmental some
of it was we were in the middle of a
move some of it was all kinds of stuff
but i'm not gonna pay the extra money to
have somebody tell me that we don't we
are unable to help your kid with the
needs they have we're unable to
support your child with the learning
challenges that they have get out yep
then i'm going to go 100 i want to say
yes and amen to that that's absolutely
right john you hear what i'm just so
jessica this alters as a parent it
alters your picture yeah of what you
thought was going to be what your kid's
trajectory was going to look like and
you got to grieve that because it stinks
and i want my kid with people who are
going to walk alongside them and love
them and honor them whatever challenges
they're they're working through whatever
exceptionalities they're working through
yep
so i want you to take another eval and i
know those are expensive i know they're
a pain in the butt you got to get on an
eight month wait list i'd love for you
to take that eval to a public school now
before it's you're backed into a corner
and you've got two weeks to to make a
decision here and there and it just gets
overwhelming i'd love for you to sit
down and say what are our options in the
upcoming school year
and then you've got months to prepare if
you're going to transition schools
you've got months to prepare your
youngster for it and
bring them all along as part of that
process it's going to be hard and nobody
likes changing schools especially young
kids but i'd much rather him in a school
that wants him there than somebody who's
already preemptively kicking him out
right
and i know that stinks i know that's
hard i know that's hard hard hard when
it comes to telling a six-year-old hey
if you do this there's gonna be
consequences of course you do that of
course i tell i got a six-year-old right
now i tell her if this behavior happens
you're opting into this consequence i do
that on a regular basis every day i do
that
but when it comes to somebody who is
struggling with
neurological challenges that are just
going to be non-neurotypical man you got
to be careful about those downstream
effects because what it feels like is
disconnection and one of the demons of
you know this better than anybody i'm
telling the general population of adhd
and of autism and that nexus where they
cross
is a body that is screaming for somebody
to see me
somebody connect with me and i don't
have the social skills or the tools or
the chaos control to reach out and
connect
and that sort of that type of rejection
just pours gasoline on that fire
and i know you know that and my heart's
breaking for you because i know what
it's like to love a kid and to say i
just walked with too many parents i love
this kid and i'm struggling with where
they fit
yeah i i couldn't agree more john i mean
the private school let's just let's just
call it what it is they've just uh
they've just straight up fired a warning
shot yeah and uh i'm not trying to bash
them i'm not saying they're they're not
good people um but um
you know our story i'm going to protect
my family as well
we have been in schools before where it
was very obvious that
they didn't want to help couldn't help
and you just have to kind of deal with
it and you have to do what's best for
your kid so i think the warning shot's
there you got to prepare i think you
gave her some practical advice and do
what's best for him jessica how does
that sit with you
um it sounds good i think it's just that
um it's not that the school doesn't want
to that they can't
him to death you know so i do want to
make that fine line it's not like
they're like oh well he's too much it's
more so that they're like they're
actually concerned like i don't think we
have the resources and they were like
crying when they told me that so i was
like okay like it so
that's the only thing but because they
love him to death and they are bending
over backwards for him but yes if they
don't have the resources then you know i
i think that that's a really smart idea
though because i do i don't want to be
rushed like last time we were blindsided
last time or you know but now we have at
least months to prepare i think that
i think that's a really good
route and also i guess my other question
is i mean i know that you guys you know
this is ramsey religious based um the
reason why we did private school mainly
for him was
sometimes he doesn't necessarily know
the difference between reality
you know like and fantasy and what is
actually true and
and so yeah you're gonna have to find a
school resource there and if he's
struggling with reality and fantasy then
yeah he's gonna have to he's gonna have
to have some support aids 100
no question about that thank you so much
for your call to wrap up today's show i
want to thank james tiles and kelly
daniels for running another great show
my good friend ken coleman and you
america we'll be right back on the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
you